the taliban recently banned poppy
cultivation in afghanistan but in
reality isn't enforcing it in fact as
you'll see a senior taliban official
told us as much so why the ban the
reasons are complex but center around
one indisputable reality
a lack of options opium cultivation for
many afghans including sometimes the
taliban is the only way to earn enough
money in a shattered economy
the brown mass oozing out of this poppy
plant is extremely valuable and right
now it's harvest time in afghanistan
farmers are collecting the raw material
necessary for opium morphine and heroin
production
but in early april the taliban forbade
poppy cultivation
if this plant is banned from cultivation
we will be forced to steal
it doesn't make any sense to harvest
other crops like maize or pomegranate
they don't yield enough profit to live
off
we visited these farmers just as this
year's crop was being harvested
for 28 years mohamed taja's family has
been cultivating opium
the extremely dry climate in south
afghanistan is ideal for the plants
we started planting opium because we
don't have enough water all the
necessary equipment for other crops
the people are poor and opium is
profitable
this farmer tells us he has 25 family
members to care for he has many children
he also grows grapes but that's not
enough to make ends meet
these bags contain his valuable product
and this is the market where the raw
opium will be sold
it's the place where local drug lords
meet they smuggle the opium to pakistan
or iran from there it is refined to
heroin and shipped around the world
including to europe
the dealers are not happy with the ban
on opium cultivation
we told the taliban they had to do
something for us first if they want us
to stop selling opium
in early april the taliban announced
they were immediately banning the
cultivation of opium
but the deputy minister for taliban drug
policy tells us this law is not being
enforced
as you can see from our announcement
we said that for the moment we will not
be taking action against farmers who
planted opium this year
if we do
many farmers will suffer great problems
in 2020 afghanistan was the world's
largest opium producer
responsible for 85 percent of global
production according to the un
the taliban taxed the cultivation and
trade of the crop earning millions of
u.s dollars and helping finance their
war
something they have never officially
admitted
ajay zani explains to us why the taliban
are trying to ban opium production
his institute collects data and
researches drug cultivation in
afghanistan
the objective is certainly to get the
approval first of the international
community
hopefully move closer and closer to a
recognition of the regime which is very
important for them because it would then
allow many other revenues to flow in
the taliban minister confirmed this in
the interview he said the world has to
help us
we ask them to take notice and stand by
our side
joining me now from istanbul is
correspondent
who's reported from afghanistan for many
years ali the taliban have banned opium
cultivation officially but as we see in
our report they don't appear to be
actively enforcing the ban
why is that you think
i mean this is the thing this is the
same issue that the republic had that
you know enforcing the ban is extremely
difficult because
on the one hand if you enforce it what
you're going to be doing is taking the
livelihood of farmers who have really
very few other options to make money you
know like during the 20 years
of the occupation the former republic
always came up with these different
schemes of you know poppy alternatives
like pomegranates or aloe vera or um
any apples any any sort of
things that they thought would somehow
or saffron that they thought would make
more money and in reality they could
never support any of those markets to
make sure that for instance those
alternative crops would either be sold
in sufficient amounts in the domestic
market or would be exported properly
around the region so to enforce it is
extremely extremely difficult and at the
same time you have to remember that you
know
the taliban in the past was involved in
the drug trade themselves they made
millions of dollars a year off of it
usually within uh by helping with the
transportation of it
the former republic too was very
complacent and very much involved you
know from the ministry of interior to
mps allied with the government to strong
men alive with the government to
ministers in the government
they also had hands uh in this uh you
know drug trade
um
so it's it's it's not so easy
then then why ban it officially why is
the taliban resort to this measure
because it's it's a nice you know
it's a nice pr it's a nice buzz to
create you know we did what allegedly
what the former republic couldn't do but
the truth is they're falling victim to
the same trap because
they're banning it as you said in words
but unable to enforce it and more
importantly not able to come up with
real sustainable alternative sources of
income
at a time when you know the economy is
absolutely suffering even more than it
was during the republic so people are
desperate for any way to make money and
obviously
you know poppy makes some money it
doesn't make as much money as the
trafficking of it does which is usually
handled by regional mafias by pakistani
and iranian and
mafias but you know it's some sort of a
reliable income for people
talk to us about those people i mean
you've traveled quite extensively
through afghanistan what have the
farmers told you for instance i mean is
opium cultivation really the only viable
option for most of them
in a lot of places you know it's it's
it grows really easy it grows fairly
easily you know um and it's something
that you know there will always be a
market for you know you know you know
that you can always sell it and on the
other hand you have instances where
especially this was a big issue with the
former republic where you know certain
strong men lived within the area and
they would essentially force you to do
it whether you wanted to or not and
basically threaten you if you weren't uh
complying uh but really you know i
remember a few years ago the us embassy
had this this meeting to talk about
essentially they admitted to failing in
the drug war
in afghanistan and when someone brought
up the issue of alternative crops they
made a really good point they said you
can never compete with an illicit
product you know the price of an illicit
product is always going to be more
valuable than any legal substance um
just because of the nature of trying to
get it and and so
farmers know this and and you know it's
something that they've been doing for so
long and it's something that they know
there is
a market for and as i said if no
government is able to come up with a
true clear sustainable alternative this
is just going to continue to be a
problem within afghanistan
we'll leave it there for today though
ali latif in istanbul thank you so much
for joining us on that thank you